hi guys my name is john uh i live in the
sierra nevada mountains in california
and my question for you guys is uh more
so directly rich but uh
you know how do you how do you address
failure and like like the colossal type
of failure the type of
failure that makes you feel like your
your life's falling apart or you know
the wheels are falling off and you can't
grab onto the reins and get controlled
things again
you know what the higher version of
yourself needs to do but you can't do it
because
all you can feel is the the lower
version of yourself
you know and uh how do you tackle things
like
guilt and shame and how do you uh
address
and like adjust your lifestyle to
set yourself up for success anyway thank
you guys i love the show
i love you guys you uh done a lot for me
and i appreciate it
thanks again bye that's heavy um i can
feel
the pain in this one yeah um
it's tough you know it sounds like
john's going through
something extremely difficult we don't
know the details of what that is
uh but i intuit a sense of of of
powerlessness
in in what he's relating right it's the
idea of the
the two wolves like which wolve do you
feed and the dark wolf
is the one who's getting the best of him
at the moment and there's a sense of
an inability to kind of arrest that
negative impulse
and i know what that feels like it's
really hard and you know for me
that was in the form of alcoholism and
the solution
that i had to come to was breaking the
chains of denial and throwing my hands
up in the air and literally
surrendering rather than trying to
control it letting go
and letting go for me meant letting
other people
in so i think the first thing i would
say to john is
you know i'm empathetic and i feel you
and i think the first thing that you can
do to um
try to get on top of this is to confront
those feelings
rather than repress them or
compartmentalize them
to find a way to bring voice to them
because things like shame can't survive
the light you've got to shine the light
on them and that's scary it takes
courage
to communicate with another person about
what you're really going through it
requires a certain
vulnerability and it's very frightening
but i
can't encourage you enough how important
it is to find somebody that
that you feel comfortable talking to
that you can be really honest with that
you can
convey whatever it is specifically
particularly specifically i think it's
important to be really specific
to let somebody in on this
and the relief that you'll experience
just in that alone
i think is tremendous you have to find
the right person somebody you can trust
somebody that you
respect somebody that you know can
provide you with
solid counsel but i think the process
of of that communication isn't
of itself a little bit of a letting go
and it will allow you to
get a little more objectivity on what's
happening with you to help you find the
cause
the triggers of those behaviors that are
sending you sideways and ultimately
help you analyze this story that you're
telling yourself that you're a failure
and you can't
you can't help yourself and everything's
out of control
to really deconstruct that and perhaps
construct a better
healthier negative less negative story
for yourself
you know along the way can you find a
way to
listen to that you know positive wolf at
all can you make
any kind of lifestyle adjustments um
that would move you in a positive
direction in recovery they call it
taking contrary action so
when your instinct is you know whether
it's like i know i shouldn't drink but
i'm going to take that drink whatever it
is like what is the contrary action like
oh
i don't want to pick up the phone and
tell that guy what i just did
the contrary action is to pick up the
phone and tell the guy what you did
right
what is the smallest contrary action
that you can take
that will break the seal on that and you
know initiate a different
direction for yourself that's a great
little uh
super doable action step to do yeah if
your mind's telling you one thing
and you know that's the negative thing
just do the smallest version of that
yeah what would the good version of
myself do and yeah as
heavy as that or whatever it you know
how difficult it is if you can just do
that one thing and you're like wow i did
that and i didn't die
yeah right um i think the other thing is
to reframe this word failure
and recast it as learning like i don't
know what this failure
colossal type of failure is specifically
again that that you're experiencing
but can we look at it instead as
a learning experience like what can you
what can be gleaned from whatever it is
that you're going through
that you can then leverage to be better
and grow
and i think in truth uh success
is about failure there isn't
success that exists outside of failure
success is about trying it's about not
being afraid to fail
and not taking failures personally and
the thing that you're attempting to do
may have failed but it's important to
de-personalize yourself from that you
didn't fail
this thing failed you had the courage to
try
so can you disassociate your identity
your sense of self
from the thing itself so that your
identity isn't tied up in how the thing
does if that makes sense right
that way you create a little bit of
distance between yourself your identity
and
your actions and at the same time
keep showing up at the plate and
you know swing the bat because if
there's one trait that successful people
share
it's that they fail way more
than they succeed they just try
so often and so regularly and we forget
about the failures we only see the
successes and this is another
message or theme of adam grant's work
like his
his book originals was all about this
like what makes people originals and
he looks at all these successful people
and realizes like these people failed
all the time whether it's picasso or or
um
edison like they have tons of failures
in their wakes and we don't look at
those or think about those we just focus
on
the few successes they had but they took
more
bats at plate than anybody else so if
you can kind of re-frame this whole
thing from that perspective
that might make it easier to get you
know back up to the plate and swing
again and
really try to objectively deconstruct
what you're going through and find the
lessons in there and
if you can do that and start figuring
out how to implement those
lessons to craft a better version of
yourself
five years from now you could look back
on whatever it is you're going through
right now and say that was the best
thing that ever happened to me and that
sounds
glib and i don't mean to be insensitive
to what you're going through
but i've heard this i've experienced
this myself and i know so many other
people that have
and maybe that'll provide you with a
little sliver of hope to dig
a little bit deeper to get yourself out
of this hole
yeah when i hear his message i think of
myself
40 years old marriage fell apart lonely
planet
jobs like going away because maybe
lonely planet is failing
that was what was happening then and um
that was the worry then
didn't fail but i saw all my income
going away
which wasn't that huge of an income
anyway
i saw my identity as a travel writer
adventure going away i didn't have
the life i thought i'd had um and then
that was just the beginning of like it
seemed like everything was working
against me just like
one thing after another and it's hard
not to take things personally when
it just keeps it you just feel like
you're in a vicious cycle
um and so i i totally feel that uh
and i know how that can i know how that
is so um
you know the only thing is it's like
weather eventually that luck turns
especially if you take these small steps
like rich laid out i would add just like
sometimes it helps
if in the morning you can do one thing
physically that is not
uh whether it's do 10 sun salutations or
sit down and try to
meditate for five or 10 minutes and turn
your brain off if you can i mean it's
hard to at first but like
one physical thing you can do first
thing in the morning right when you get
up
so at least that time right after that
you kind of feel good
yeah a little self-care just a little
bit uh and the quote
caramel yeah uh can you look at this
as something that is happening not to
you but for you
and that's beautiful i love that yeah
and i say that you have your version of
this story
look you know i've hit bottom as an
alcoholic
i've been unemployable i've been in a
situation where my family didn't want
anything to do with me i've had cars
repossessed i almost lost my house i've
been
unable to pay my bill i've had so many
you know
versions of feeling like a failure
and have been able to claw out of it so
i don't know what
john's circumstances are but i do
believe and trust that no matter where
he is there is a better place for him
and there's always
light at the end of the tunnel there you
[Music]
go
[Music]
you